build anything with Notebook LM. Here's
how Notebook LM just became something
completely different. And I'm not
talking about a small update. I'm
talking about the kind of upgrade that
makes you stop and go, "Wait, this thing
can do that now?" Because yeah, it can.
You can now build full research systems,
content engines, sales tools, and
strategy machines all inside one free
Google tool. And today, I'm going to
show you exactly how, step by step, with
real examples you can steal right now.
So, if you've ever uploaded a document
to Notebook LM and thought, "Cool, but
what do I actually do with this, this
video is for you. Stay with me because
by the end of this, you're going to see
this tool completely differently." Let's
start simple. Notebook LM is a Google AI
tool. You upload stuff to it. PDFs,
Google Docs, YouTube links, websites,
research papers, whatever. It reads all
of it. Then, you have a conversation
with it about everything you uploaded.
Ask questions, get summaries, pull out
insights. That's the basic idea. But
here's where most people get it wrong.
They treat it like a search engine. They
upload one document, ask one question,
and move on. That's like buying a
Ferrari and only using it to go to the
shops. The real power is in how you set
it up, what you feed it, and how you
instruct it to think. And that's exactly
what changed in this update. So, let me
break it down properly. Hey, if we
haven't met already, I'm the digital
avatar of Julian Goldie, CEO of SEO
agency Goldie Agency. Whilst he's
helping clients get more leads and
customers, I'm here to help you get the
latest AI updates. Julian Goldie reads
every comment, so make sure you comment
below. The biggest change under the hood
is the context upgrade. Here's what that
means in plain English. Before this
update, Notebook LM could only really
process a limited chunk of your uploaded
material at one time. So, if you had a
big notebook with loads of sources, the
answers you got were kind of shallow. It
was skimming the surface. It couldn't
hold all of it in its head at once. Now
that's changed. The system has been
rebuilt to process significantly more
information in a single conversation,
which means when you ask a question,
it's pulling from everything, not just
the first few pages of the first
document it finds. The answers are
sharper. The references are more
accurate. There's way less AI guessing
going on. Think of it like this. Old
Notebook LM was like hiring an
assistant, and they only had time to
skim your files before the meeting. New
Notebook LM actually read everything,
took notes, and came prepared. That's a
completely different experience. And for
anyone doing real research, real content
work, or real business strategy, that
difference is massive. Here's another
thing that changed. The conversations
are smarter now, and they actually hold
context properly over a long session.
Before, if you were going deep on a
topic and asked a lot of follow-up
questions, the AI would start to lose
the thread. It would forget what you
said 10 messages ago. It would give you
answers that contradicted what it told
you earlier. That was frustrating. Now
you can have long layered conversations
that actually build on themselves. You
can explore a topic from multiple angles
without having to reset or reexlain
everything. This makes it genuinely
useful for things like research
projects, building out a content
strategy, planning a product launch, or
working through a complex business
problem. The conversation doesn't fall
apart halfway through. It stays
coherent. That sounds small, but
honestly, it changes everything about
how usable this tool is. Quick one
before we go deeper. Now, if you're
watching this and thinking, I want to be
using AI tools like this to actually
grow my business, then you need to know
about the AI profit boardroom. It's our
private community where we go deep on
exactly this stuff. How to use tools
like Notebook LM, not just to play
around, but to build real systems that
save you time and grow your business. We
cover AI automation, content workflows,
lead generation systems, all of it. If
you want to be the person on your team
who actually knows how to use AI
properly, this is where you need to be.
Link is in the description. Go check it
out now and I'll see you inside. Okay,
this is the feature that most people are
sleeping on. And it's honestly the most
powerful thing in this whole update. You
can now give Notebook LM extremely
detailed custom instructions. And I mean
really detailed. You're not just
uploading documents and asking questions
anymore. You are literally telling the
AI how to think, how to structure its
answers, what to prioritize, how to
handle conflicting information, and what
kind of voice and approach to use. You
are designing the brain of your research
assistant. Let me give you a real
practical example using the AI profit
boardroom. Let's say I want to build a
growth strategy tool for our community.
I'd upload everything. Our offer page,
member feedback, our best performing
content, onboarding materials,
competitor research, community
engagement data. Then I'd write custom
instructions like this. You are a growth
strategist for the AI profit boardroom.
Your job is to help us get more members,
increase engagement, and clearly
communicate the value of AI automation
to business owners. When answering
questions, always back your answers up
with specific evidence from the sources.
Be direct, skip the fluff, and always
think about what action we should take
next. Now, that notebook isn't just a
file storage system with a chat box.
It's a dedicated growth strategist for
our community trained on our actual data
thinking about our specific goals. You
ask it anything. How do we improve
retention? What content is resonating?
Where are people dropping off? And it
gives you real grounded evidence-based
answers, not generic AI advice, actual
insights from your actual material. That
is a completely different level of
usefulness. Let me walk you through some
real things you can build right now.
First, a content strategy engine. Upload
your best performing blog posts, your
YouTube scripts, your email campaigns,
competitor content you admire, and your
brand positioning dock. Set instructions
telling it to act as a content
strategist focused on attracting
business owners interested in AI
automation. Then ask it for your top
content ideas based on what's already
working. Ask it to identify patterns in
your highest performing content. Ask it
what topics your audience keeps coming
back to. It reads everything and gives
you a content plan built on real data,
not guesswork. Second, a sales and offer
research tool. Upload your offer page,
customer questions you've received,
objections you hear on sales calls,
competitor offers, and community
feedback. Instruct it to act as a sales
analyst for the AI profit boardroom,
focused on understanding why people
join, why they don't, and how to sharpen
the offer. Then ask it what the top
objections are, what the strongest
selling points are, and where the
messaging could be clearer. You now have
a dedicated sales analyst running on
your real customer data. Third, a
community growth engine. Upload member
feedback, your most engaged posts,
retention data, onboarding materials,
and anything members have told you about
what they love or find confusing.
Instruct it to act as a community growth
expert. Then ask it what content drives
the most engagement, what new members
struggle with in their first week, and
how you could improve the onboarding
flow. This used to require hiring a
consultant. Now you can get those
insights in minutes from a notebook you
built yourself. There are three more
features worth knowing about. First is
the upgraded audio mode. Notebookm can
now generate different styles of audio
analysis from your sources, quick
summaries, critical analysis, or
opposing viewpoint discussions. For the
AI profit boardroom, I'd use this to run
a critical analysis on our own training
content. Upload a module, ask it to
challenge the arguments, find the weak
spots, and identify where we need more
evidence. That's a quality control tool
running on demand. or use the opposing
viewpoints format to understand both
sides of a debate in your niche and turn
that into a podcast episode or YouTube
script. Second is structured data
tables. You can now ask Notebook LM to
generate comparison tables directly from
your sources. Upload three competitor
community offers and ask it to build a
table comparing features, pricing,
positioning, and unique angles against
the AI profit boardroom. That
competitive analysis used to take hours.
Now it's one prompt and 30 seconds.
Third is visual output control. You now
have much more control over how
information is presented. You can
specify layout, detail level, and
format. Ask for a slide ready bullet
point summary, a one-page brief, or a
structured report. For weekly AI
updates, I'd upload the week's top news.
Ask for a clean summary formatted for a
presentation and send it to our
community in minutes. This is where the
whole thing levels up. Notebook LM now
integrates with Google Gemini. What this
means practically is that you can use
your notebooks as source material inside
Gemini when you're creating content. So
your workflow becomes research and
organizing notebookm then creating
Gemini powered by your curated sources
for the AI profit boardroom. That means
building a master knowledge base in
notebook LM everything about our
community, our members, our offer, our
results and then using Gemini to write
emails, ads, landing pages and content
that's all grounded in that specific
knowledge. No more generic AI output.
Everything is trained on your business,
your voice, your data. You're
essentially building a custom AI
assistant that actually knows who you
are. Here's the truth about where all of
this is heading. AI is creating a split
and it's happening right now. On one
side, you've got basic users. People who
open chat GPT, type a question, get a
mediocre answer, and think that's what
AI is. On the other side, you've got
power users. People who build systems,
define instructions, feed in real data,
and get outputs that genuinely move
their business forward. Notebook LM is
one of the most powerful free tools
available right now for becoming a power
user. And the people who get good at
this early are going to have a serious
advantage over everyone who's still just
winging it with random prompts. Right,
that's the full breakdown. Notebook LM
is not a notes app anymore. It's a
system builder. And now you know exactly
how to use it. If you want to go even
deeper on this and learn how to build
real AI systems for your business, come
join us in the AI profit boardroom. We
break down tools like this step by step,
show you exactly how to implement them,
and help you build workflows that
actually save you time and grow your
business. No fluff, no theory, it's just
practical stuff that works. Link is in
the description. And if you want the
full process, all the SOPs, and over 100
AI use cases like this one, completely
free, join the AI Success Lab. We've got
over 40,000 members inside already, all
using AI to work smarter and move
faster. All the notes from today's video
are in there, too. Link is in the
comments and the description. and go
grab it now and I'll see you